ليست فيكتوريا جراي معتاده الشهره ام من
ولايه ميسيسيبي الامريكيه
لكنها خطفت الاضواء في قمه تعديل الجينوم
البشري في لندن التي تحضرها للحديث عن
العلاج الذي غير حياتها
اعتقد انه شيء رائع من منا لا يريد حياه
جيده خاليه من المعاناه لم اختر مرضي
لكنني ولدت به وكبر معي شفيت فيكتوريا من
مرض فقر الدم المنجلي من خلال علاج تجريبي
لتعديل الجينات تمثل قصتها تقدما كبيرا قد
يؤثر في الملايين من الاشخاص الذين يولدون
بمرض دم نادر كل عام الامراض الوراثيه مثل
الخلايا المنجليه والتليف الكيسي وانتن
تبدا كتغيرات في الجينات وهي تلك الرموز
الموجوده في الحمض النووي البشري الذي
تخبر الجسم بكيفيه تكوين الخلايا يمكن
للادوات الجديده مثل ما تسمى تقنيه كريسبر
للتعديل الجيني ان تحدث فرقه فهي تتيح
ايجاد وقطع واستبدال الاجزاء المعيبه من
جينات الكائنات الحيه لتقديم شفره جنيه
مصححه
ويسعى العلماء لاستخدامها في توفير علاج
سريع وفعال للطفرات الجينيه مما يفتح
افاقا جديده في الطب الوراثي لكن تم مخاوف
منها واحده من هذه المخاوف هي استخدام
تكنولوجيا تعديل الجينوم لتغيير الاجنه
البشريه لاغراض الانجاب فقد شاب جدل القمه
السابقه لتعديل الجينوم البشري عام 2018
في هونغ كونغ عندما كاشف العالم الصيني هي
جان كوي انه تمكن من انتاج اول طفلتين
معدلتين وراثيا في العالم
وهما توامان سماهما لولو ونانا وقد عدل
الحمض النووي
للطفلتين بينما كانت في مرحله جنينيه
بطريقه قال جيان كوي انها ستجعلهما
مقاومتين للاصابه بفيروس نقص المناعه
المكتسب الايتس وهو ما قبل حينها باستنكار
شديد من قبل العلماء وادى الى سجن العالم
ثلاثه اعوام يقول فريق دولي من العلماء ان
تعديل الجنون في اثناء الحمل ليس امنا
والتقنيه ليست جاهزه بعد ويخشى العلماء من
ان عيادات الخصوبه يمكن ان تستخدم
التكنولوجيا لتقديم خدمات تعديل الجينات
وتحسين النسل لانتاج ما يطلق عليه اطفال
وفق الطلب وبينما تشق التكنولوجيا تعديل
الشفره الجينيه لعلاج الامراض النادره
طريقها من المراحل التجريبيه الى العمليه
وان كان بتكلفه باهظه الان يبقى التحدي
الاكبر هو جعلها في متناول الناس وباسعار
معقوله